Olá, meus queridos. Vamos lá. Vou
mostrar como é que faz para se inscrever
no nível dois. Eu tô aqui em outra conta
do YouTube. Eu digitei aqui
youtube.com/c/dralaindutra.
É um dos jeitos de entrar. Outro jeito é
alindutra.com/appoia.
Tá bom? Se eu clicar assim, eu caio
direto
na inscrição, tá? Então vocês vão ter
duas opções aqui, extras mais WhatsApp,
que é o grupo que vocês estão agora, ou
estudos avançados. Se eu clicar aqui
seja membro,
ele já vai pra tela para confirmar
identidade, CPF, data de nascimento.
Eu não vou colocar aqui, não vou
preencher aqui, tá? Mas dando
confirmação aqui, é só dar sequência no
que o YouTube pede, tá? Então é simples
assim.
Se eu fosse
pela outra forma, ó,
youtube.com/c/dralaindutra
ou você pode fazer a pesquisa dentro do
YouTube pelo meu canal, você pode fazer
a mesma coisa aqui, ó, seja membro e
clicar aqui na segunda opção. No.